a horrific car crash that set a woman's
life into ruin tonight police are
re-examining their investigation the
crash seriously hurt a woman in her 70s
and the driver was barely sighted even
though he didn't have a license or a
registration eight news now investigator
Kyle Payne has the update tonight
Maria omond is in her 70s she says her
life was ruined the night of the crash
and she couldn't believe it when we told
her the driver who hit her and her
walker couldn't produce a license or
insurance and had expired registration
on his out-of-state plates so we looked
into it and questioned the police crash
report and now the police are doing the
very same thing I should have been dead
God spared my life don't ask me why
I'm serious the doctor said an inch and
a half more and I would have been dead
not dead but not in good shape either 77
year old Maria omond is still dealing
with her injuries and other unfortunate
Fallout from this night in January when
she was hit by a car in the stretch of
road behind her apartment she was sent
to the hospital and said she was stuck
there in rehab for 74 days the miracle
is I have no broken bones and no
internal bleeding but her leg was
bleeding and even after two surgeries
she worries she might have to have it
amputated
her walker was trapped underneath the
car that hit her a Volvo
that driver didn't see Maria omont
before he hit her which police said was
an accident but the driver also had an
expired registration no license and
didn't show proof of insurance but he
was only cited for failure to pay
attention this is private property okay
but R8 news now investigation revealed
the road connecting these two rows of
apartment buildings is in fact a public
right-of-way meaning the police could
have cited the driver for any of those
violations and when we questioned Metro
about it they agreed telling us in a
statement in part quote the officer
determined the accident occurred on a
private property the officer determined
the accident occurred on the public
right-of-way he would have issued
additional citations but no arrest would
have been made the traffic accident has
been amended to reflect the incident did
occur on the public right-of-way the
traffic Bureau will determine if
additional traffic citations will be
issued to the driver this could have
been all avoided if he did what he was
supposed to do I spoke with Maria after
our story ran she's seriously
considering hiring a lawyer and even
though she appreciated our story she
says it doesn't do much for her
excruciating pain Kyle Payne 8 News now
you can watch Kyle's investigation into
the crash on our website 8newsnow.com